[Musica]
avete conservato tutti questo
è il biglietto per accedere no lo chiedo
perché io li conservo tutti i biglietti
degli eventi per la gioia di mia moglie
Irene e io dico che ha un valore
affettivo Comunque quel biglietto Però
credo almeno potenzialmente che l'anno
prossimo per esempio il 3DS di Cremona
potrebbe avere un biglietto che ha un
valore anche economico provo a
spiegarvelo partendo da me e partendo da
questa frase che ho letto qualche
settimana fa che dice di un poeta che
dice sostanzialmente che le esperienze e
le passioni che scopriamo nei primi
Vent'anni sono le più importanti per
tutta la nostra vita a prescindere da
quanti anni poi viviamo io ho passato i
40 anni da poco e ho incominciato a
chiedermi se è vero Ho cominciato a
pensare alla musica Beh effettivamente i
musicisti che ascoltavano nei primi 20
anni ancora oggi le canzoni sono sono le
mie preferite e poi ho pensato alle
altre passioni il basket e il basket
effettivamente anche oggi mi piace
mi piace donch mi piace LeBron James
Però per me il basket è lui è Michael
Jordan per me perché sono cresciuto in
quel periodo lì un'altra passione è
l'informatica il computer questo qui è
il primo Atari che ho avuto poi da lì il
PC con internet e da piccolo nerd Quale
eroe da Nerd che comunque sono rimasto
un po' più cresciuto e con internet
cercavo di scoprire quello che sarebbe
successo che non l'aveva capito nessuno
se non David Bowie e pochi altri artisti
Cioè tutta la rivoluzione che c'è stata
Eh successivamente Ma la la I primi
vent'anni della mia vita sono stati
contraddistinti anche dal cambiamento
inteso come case perché hanno cambiato
più di 11 o 12 e cambiamento nel senso
che i miei genitori appena nato dopo
otto mesi hanno deciso di trasferirsi
dalla parte opposta del pianeta da Roma
a Macao cioè Cina Hong Kong e ed è stato
abbastanza più difficile e i miei
genitori mi raccontavano che ero
preoccupati perché a tre anni ancora non
sapevo parlare però del resto in casa
parlavano italiano a scuola cinese i
vicini erano Portoghesi australiani
Insomma era abbastanza complesso e però
questa voglia di scoprire di vedere dei
nuovi mondi Uniti alla tecnologia mi
sono accorto che effettivamente che era
quello dei primi vent'anni ancora oggi
lo porto avanti lo porto avanti nel mio
lavoro e la nuova frontiera tecnologica
credo che siano gli nft Allora
tranquilli che non vi farò una
spiegazione di tecnica di cosa siano
però questa qua che vedete è un'immagine
questa che vediamo un'immagine un
volgarissimo JPEG Se volete In verità è
collegato a un nfp e questo nft è stato
venduto per 69 milioni 69 milioni ed è
successo un anno e mezzo fa
Probabilmente è stato lo spartiacque
Cioè da quel momento le persone di
questo settore hanno cominciato a dire
Beh non può essere un fenomeno
passeggero momentaneo perché tra l'altro
gli nft si scrivono su blockchain e si
scambiano con le criptovalute e quindi
uno a un certo punto potrebbe pensare va
bene il deep web le cripto Chissà No è
stato battuto all'asta da christie's
cioè una delle più grosse case d'asta al
mondo e per chi ha sentito poche volte
parlare di blockchain e criptovalute
magari sui giornali dove se va bene si
cita come speculazione o truffa vi dico
che in verità la blockchain e le
criptovalute sono nate per tutt'altro E
tutt'oggi svolgono anche altre funzioni
poi ci sono anche le truffe perché
quando ci sono delle nuove tecnologie e
così e facciamo un salto indietro alla
fine degli anni 80 c'era un movimento di
ti cyberpunks cypher crittografia queste
persone già alla fine degli anni 80
avevano intuito che c'è qualcosa che non
va con il proliferare dei dati prima con
il computer poi con le reti poi con
internet ma l'avevo già intuito non va
bene a me non sta bene che i miei dati
che possono essere visibili a degli
ospedali e dei militari e dei governi a
chi che sia per cui dobbiamo trovare un
modo per crittografarli per diventare di
nuovo padrone dei nostri dati e decidere
noi quando mostrarli e quando no Ora
Questa è la copertina di Wired giornale
del 93 e parla di ribelli con una causa
che appunto la nostra privacy e i nostri
dati erano dei ribelli Ma erano degli
accademici erano degli Imprenditori
erano dei manager dentro c'era tra le
varie persone che ci sono cresciute
dentro tutte le persone di WikiLeaks
Giuliana sanges abbiamo dei grandissimi
fondatori di aziende e poi abbiamo
Satoshi nakamoto che non sappiamo se una
donna se un uomo se un gruppo di persone
È uno pseudonimo Ma sa quello che
sappiamo che nel 2009 Da Genio ha
inventato Bitcoin ha detto ho inventato
il sistema di pagamenti peer to peer di
transazioni peer to peer quello che è
Importante sottolineare è che è una rete
completamente
decentralizzata Cioè non c'è un centro
non c'è qualcuno che autorizza come una
banca e per noi che scambiamo cripto è
abbastanza normale però io mi immagino
un ragazzo piccolo di oggi come mio
figlio Francesco per esempio che ha otto
anni fa 10 anni sono convinto che mi
dirà papà ma davvero nel 2022 tu se
dovevi mandare i soldi alla zia cioè mia
sorella Tu devi collegarti a un'app di
una banca chiedere l'autorizzazione
forse prima delle 16:30 sabato e
domenica no E poi il giorno dopo cioè
avete capito follia e probabilmente sarà
così comunque rete decentralizzata per
le transazioni che avvengono in
automatico senza che nessuno le
autorizzi Da lì poi abbiamo un nome e un
cognome del genio in questione che
vitalik booterin un ragazzo canadese un
programmatore
nostro papà appassionato di Bitcoin e
gliene parla lui fa Wow rete
decentralizzata per le transazioni ma da
programmatore dice Ma se questa rete
decentralizzata oltre che fare le
transazioni il facilissimo fare proprio
delle applicazioni che in automatico
avvengono quelli che vengono chiamati
Smart Contract Ecco è la nascita di
ethereum che la seconda blockchain più
grossa al mondo ed è soprattutto la base
sulla quale nascono la maggior parte
degli nft
Non dirò nulla di tecnico l'ho già detto
ma quello che ci tengo a sottolineare è
che non è un NFC non è un'immagine non è
un file audio non è un file video è un
certificato digitale al quale noi
possiamo legare naturalmente immagini
video audio o altri file digitali Ma per
la prima volta nella storia del digitale
noi possiamo dare un'unicità a un file
noi oggi per la prima volta possiamo
dire chi è il proprietario chi era il
proprietario della settimana scorsa e
magari per quanti soldi solo sono
scambiato e addirittura Chi è colui il
quale ha creato questo In effetti
artista Brand azienda chi vogliamo e chi
lo ha creato ha facoltà di decidere una
royalty una percentuale che guadagnerà
per tutte le successive rivendite future
video nel mercato dell'arte che
rivoluzione perché è dai tempi di
Napster e Torrent Adesso lo dico per gli
over 20 e c'è una telecamera quindi non
dirò che computer con Napster
scaricavamo no video audio foto se le
ricordiamo abbastanza perché eravamo
diventati maghi del copia incolla Ma di
chi è quel file lì ma chi se ne frega
copia e incolla lo passo a un amico lo
passo a qualcun altro Ecco da adesso
abbiamo un modo per dire quel file lì
per la prima volta di chi è
e è nato dall'arte Come spesso accade
con tutte le nuove tecnologie ma ormai
il mondo degli nft si sta allargando a
tantissimi mercati per la rivoluzione
più grossa è proprio il rapporto che c'è
con chi ha l'nft io faccio progetti di
nft e con i primi che ho fatto ricordo
delle persone che mi dicono Diego ma chi
ha comprato il mio nfp non è più solo un
fan un cliente o uno spettatore è quasi
un socio perché è quasi un socio perché
tanto investito dei soldi e io se quella
nft aumenta di prezzo Sono contento
intanto perché è scritto su blockchain è
scritto sulla pietra e rimane per sempre
e tutti lo possono vedere ma se aumenta
il prezzo viene scambiato io ci guadagno
e d'altro canto la persona che è all'
nfp se aumenta il prezzo dell'nft è
contento perché può rivenderlo
liberamente immediatamente dovremo
trovare una parola che sta in mezzo tra
fan cliente spettatore e so e poi noi
nerd insomma questa parola ce l'abbiamo
già e in inglese si chiama holder per
cui se io dico che sono holder di un
particolare nft o progetto ci capiamo
già non sono un fan di sono un holder
sono un qualcosa di più
e naturalmente non mancano i problemi e
quando Presenta i progetti spesso sento
mille obiezioni e ce n'è una in
particolare che sento che mi dicono sì
va bene Diego belli questi nft però mi
stai proponendo mi stai dicendo delle
cose che potremmo tranquillamente fare
senza gli nft Secondo me nel 90% dei
casi non è vero ma mi viene in mente un
video che avevo già visto tantissime
volte ed è del 1995 in cui un
giovanissimo Bill Gates Microsoft viene
intervistato da David lettermann uno dei
più grossi giornalisti all'epoca e David
Letterman gli dice Vabbè tu il tuo
obiettivo è vendere un computer per ogni
ufficio un computer per ogni casa perché
questo era l'obiettivo del 95 della
Microsoft E lui dice guarda come è già
fallito perché io che ci devo fare un
computer o la segretaria il computer fa
qualcosa in più della segretaria no E
quindi non mi serve è già e comincia un
pochino Poi poi dice Ma lo sai che mi
hanno mi volevano conoscere a prendere
internet Ma lo sai perché mi hanno detto
che con internet Io potrei ascoltare le
partite mai sentito parlare della radio
e lo prendono in giro Bill Gates Prova a
difendersi dice Sì capisco anche se
magari la puoi salvare quella partita e
sul tuo hard disk condividerla e poi
riascoltarla quando vuoi
come l'audio cassetta Cioè capite lo
dico per i più giovani Quella è la era
la normalità non era strano David
Letterman come anche se parlavamo di
dire apri una casella di posta
elettronica una delle risposte che
sentivamo è Ma perché c'è il fax che
bisogna cioè di mandare una mail di
posta elettronica che non so cos'è come
funziona perché è più complesso per
provare a ragionare in questi termini
e solo che qualche anno dopo l'ONU 2011
dichiara l'accesso ad internet un
diritto dell'uomo fondamentale
cambiata un po' di tempo ma
effettivamente oggi Se provate proviamo
a pensare qualcuno che non abbia
internet o che non abbia una casella di
posta deve andare in un ufficio pubblico
piuttosto che aprire un conto in banca è
veramente complesso
torniamo sugli nfp questo qua avete
sentito parlare qua c'è la festival
quest'anno in Italia è diventato famoso
Perché i maneskin hanno suonato
probabilmente il festival più più di
musica più importante al mondo e
quest'anno per la prima volta hanno
emesso degli nft che valgono come
biglietti per un giorno per due giorni E
peraltro e questo che vediamo invece è
un biglietto e un nfp che vale l'accesso
per due persone a vita al qua c'è la
festival capite che chi l'ha comprato
Non è uno spettatore del coccio alla
festival e qualcuno che è investito che
ci ha creduto Infatti lo ha pagato
migliaia di euro e naturalmente spera
che continui a esistere qua c'è la
festival altrimenti e lo potrà vendere e
si potranno collegare tante esperienze
per esempio chi ha questo nft ha dei
diritti aggiuntivi fisici ma ogni mese
può partecipare a delle dirette con
degli Artisti avere in anteprima molte
più informazioni Insomma il limite è lì
la fantasia
Forse avete capito perché all'inizio vi
dicevo del biglietto perché
potenzialmente l'anno prossimo il TX di
Cremona potrebbe avere un nfp che vale
come biglietto Adesso non voglio dare
una croce aggiuntiva ai Volontari del TX
di Cremona che ne hanno già abbastanza
Però potrebbe essere E per favore non
venitemi a cercare tra un anno dire
Diego avevi detto che se succede non
succede Non è questa la cosa importante
quello che penso io che sia veramente
importante è Dior
No non è una pubblicità occulta è
un'altra parola da Nerd che utilizziamo
un acronimo che sta per Do your home
Research Perché Perché il cambiamento
arriva lo abbiamo capito Non importa che
siano i tuoi genitori che ti obbligano
ad andare da una parte opposta del
pianeta non importa se la tua azienda
che ti obbliga a cambiare lavoro o la
tua famiglia che ti obbliga a fare
qualche cosa o se sei tu che tipo di un
obiettivo e decidi di cambiare quello
che è importante è formarsi va bene
ascoltare qualcuno in televisione
qualcuno su un palco Ma la cosa
importante è studiare quindi Buona
ricerca
[Applauso]